okay what I want to say my first
question was that they say no
explanation is Meaningful unless it's
empirically verified instead of saying
no claim statement is
meaningless which is self-refuting yes
they say no explanation is Meaningful so
how do you refute
that that's a difficult that's
interesting right because now it's no
longer really a statement right but then
you could also ask well how do you make
that statement
meaningful
and you can kind of dissect it in this
way like I say you can ask what if if
the explanation is only meaningful based
on science and why is the statement
meaningful and if they say if they give
you a reason why then ask them why
you're not being consistent in that
respect why is it that the mean the
statement is saved but the explanation
is not see what I'm saying why are you
using two different criteria
here okay are The Logical truths
themselves a priority because they two
are analytic what makes them so
okay um I hate to say this because I'm
going to be opposing some of the other
people you've you've spoken to or you've
learned from but I don't believe logic
is a
priori um I believe logic is
language that's it um I believe that we
can have
inclinations like I believe for instance
that the fthra is an inclination towards
belief in God I believe that um there's
an inclination towards towards causation
like a perspective you know what I mean
like I can see causation but a belief or
a logical formula being innate that
doesn't make any sense like if I told
you the law of non-contradiction you
don't really understand what that is I
mean you can perceive it but if I told
you what it was at the first time in
your life you would never you wouldn't
get what I'm saying if I showed you the
logical formulation of that you would
not understand right I'd have to teach
it to you
but you are inclined to it you're
inclined to naturally perceive the world
is not contradicting itself see what I'm
saying so that's why I would not say
that logical truths are a priori because
logical laws logical truths you know
what I mean aren't aren't really those
are things that we write those are
things that we have we have expressed
through
language if if logic is reduced to
language does language a priority then I
don't think language is a priority
either
everyone's like
why I'm sorry I ruined your day I
know I'm I'm out of water oh
goodness it do trust me if you guys are
freaking out because something's not a
priority don't there's nothing something
doesn't have to be a priority to be true
or to be axiomatic in some respect like
it you know um like your fit throw is is
not based on whether or not it's a prior
your f is your F it's all you have you
can take a more consequentialist
approach in saying that okay well this
is all I have to perceive the world like
your brain is what you get right you're
created with this brain this is all you
have so you can't be like um is this
true or not you know what I mean is this
is this Justified like what other
criteria you going to use you see what
I'm saying like well you can't go
outside of your brain and say does my
brain work no you don't know like that's
all you have
uh how's my health alhamdulillah I'm
doing okay I'm I'm recovering as you can
see I'm not exactly up to par still but
I'm working on
it uh can you could you please expand on
your comment on Anthony reason becoming
idea is not good enough I don't believe
physical observation of the world can
directly infer
God that's why similarly I don't believe
that finding scientific miracles in the
Quran is a good reason because I believe
science is is not is does not operate in
that fashion you cannot find Science in
the Quran because science is constantly
changing doesn't make any
sense uh what are your views on Paul
farin's on scientific anarchism
anarchism what is his place in the
philosophy of science his place in the
philosophy of science was very
interesting because he completely tries
to undermine everyone's else's position
he's the most annoying he's one of those
really annoying philosophers that comes
around and just goes hey all hey all of
you guys you're all wrong and I don't
know if I'm right but you're all wrong
that's he's that
guy he he he um he's wrong I think and I
think everyone else thinks he's wrong
but he he asked a lot of interesting
questions which helped the philosophical
Community flesh out their theories
better so he was sort of that guy who
came along and poked you enough to make
you have a a better
position what argument do you use for
the existence of got other than the
F other than the
f I don't like those arguments I don't
like many other arguments other than
that to be honest um I suppose I would
say the T logical argument is the best
one you can
get but I mean every argument can be
challenged to some
degree um that's the
problem because no one has absolute
knowledge now
I would probably say that
um yeah the te logical argument is
probably the best the design argument I
mean like everything looks
designed therefore it must be designed
and people say that's very simple just
because it looks designed doesn't mean
it's designed but then if you argue well
if that's the only way I can look at it
how can you say otherwise that's when
you kind of combine the two the F it's
like well I can't say I can't say it's
not designed because my my
perception doesn't doesn't doesn't allow
me to say otherwise like I see
everything as designed I can't do
anything else about it so what am I
supposed to do it's like if you tell
somebody you live in a matrix well I
don't see the Matrix what am I gonna do
about it you
know what about contingency argument
like Al gazali's contingency
arguments I like I said guys uh a lot of
the arguments that you're mentioning
colam and such like this these for me
for me personally are arguments that
help to solidify the belief of the
believer they don't help with atheist
if you want to deal with an atheist you
have to go after their beliefs first you
have to undermine their perception of
Science and their perception of reason
and
Truth okay you're not going to win
against an atheist with these arguments
I'm sorry I know that's my personal view
you don't have to agree with me but I in
my experience with atheism over the
years it doesn't
work because unless you destroy their
their foundations first for what they
perceive to be as evidence and reason
you're not going to get anywhere they
can just keep denying your arguments
because they're not scientifically based
right you first need to this is why I
said this lecture is the most important
one the next one you have is going to be
even more important hopefully uh because
I think Hamza is going to be mentioning
how science and Islam don't contradict
he might go into more depth in this
respect but you need to understand these
beliefs you will not get anywhere with
atheist or atheism unless you understand
what science and scientism are you just
can't it's not
possible
difference between knowledge and beliefs
it's a good question and we're going to
get into that lecture a later point in
my lecture on is Islam logical I'm going
to be explaining what justification is
and warrant are Etc and what difference
between belief and knowledge
are
um uh people usually use the words
belief and knowledge a very cloaky away
and the problem with a lot of debates
today especially online is you have a
lot of people who don't understand
anything that's what the internet has
done is there's a lot a lot of lay
people a lot of like armchair Scholars
to come around and express their own
views you know
um so a belief for some people I've
noticed that atheist will use belief in
a way that just means
opinion like an opinion that like you're
not certain about but that's not what
belief is a belief is is something you
actually have a firm you have an
affirmation of like if I say I believe
in evolution it means that I I think you
know there's some content there Worth
adhering to right or I believe in Islam
which is more important right it means
that I believe that Islam is true you
know what I mean so belief is not
something separate from knowledge now
whenever you declare it that way that
means you actually know something you're
when you declare belief you're declaring
knowledge of the subject so if somebody
says I believe God does not exist
they're saying that they know in some
respect that he doesn't in the same way
if somebody says I believe God does
exist they're saying this to respect
that they believe that he does right so
some people try to demarcate between the
two but it's nonsense there is no
demarcation if you say if you say in my
opinion I believe that you know you're
just saying that you know this and
you're just trying to be like going
around the bush right it's the same
thing or ask questions just because you
want to to entertain me or vice versa I
can do a very good Richard Dawkins
accent but I don't know if I can do it
right
now
um let's see Abu farz is the universe
beginningless as argued by many
contemporary atheists helenic and Arabic
philosophers no I don't believe so I
don't believe there's any reason to
believe it's beginning list um there's
no reason to I don't see a purpose
behind that I don't I don't think the
arguments are
convincing my orange juice is
coming if you have any questions about
the material please um ask now I will
answer them later if you want this is
find as well I do expect you guys to
read my article on Yen Institute so you
can understand the birth of Science in
Islamic civilization I was hoping to get
to it here but because we had explained
so much and I kind of ranting didn't get
that
far but I do expect you guys to read it
and I've also provided additional
reading material I want you guys to pick
up this book you can get a line in PDF
if you want um but I prefer to have
hardbacks for especially important books
like this the structure of scientific
revolutions this is the Third Edition I
believe it's the fourth edition though
it's a little bit dry but if you really
want to understand Thomas and how
revolutionary his beliefs are in terms
of science and what he did to change the
world because he did change the world in
terms of how science is understood and
maybe not among the normal population
but among Scholars among people who
actually you know study science he was
the main he was the big
deal um it's a very short work it's only
a couple hundred maybe let me see it's
like okay
like 200 pages but big script okay um
it's kind of dry but he explains his
theory he explains paradigms he explains
everything and uh I think it'll open
your eyes a lot more uh I'm hoping that
this lecture was a good primer for you
that you learned a lot you understood
some things I hope you go and find more
information about the people that I
mention about the ideas that I mention I
hope you ask more questions in the
future and I hope that you enjoyed and
benefited from this lecture I apologize
there wasn't much Islam material in here
the problem is that we're focusing on a
subject that needs a lot of attention in
order for you to ascertain atheist
thought and
um unfortunately you know a lot of
Islamic scholars today do not have the
tools necessary to do that
um so um we need to kind of start
ascertaining this uh at a higher level
and I need to really focus on these
aspects only so I apologize for that if
you felt little a little bit under
underwhelmed in that respect but um I do
consider this the same as I consider any
of my other academic lectures so I do
hope that I also my my lack of Health
was not a detriment as
well um let's see I will answer the rest
of these questions and then we can leave
it at that excuse me Muhammad Zia before
this lecture I thought it was K who
first rejected pure reason or made pure
reason a supplement to empirical science
but this lecture makes it seem like the
rejection of pure reason was more of an
accumulative
effort um it it was more of yeah a
discussion between philosophers starting
with theart Hume okay deart came first
from modern philosophy Hume responded to
deart Kant responded to
Hume Hegel responded to Kant or
fulfilled
kant's you know uh
Paradigm heiger responded to Hegel okay
the analytical philosophers in the west
then resp responded to them uh more
sorry excuse me other attical
philosophers responded to them then you
get all the way to and then you get
wittenstein then you get a bunch of
other people all these philosophical
ideas are all responses to each other
that's the funny thing you know it's not
like they all come out of thin air
everyone's responding to everyone
else
that's to what degree can the coonan
Paradigm shifts be applied to religion
on non-fundamental issues a lot he
didn't intend for that to happen but uh
thean concept of Paradigm has been
applied everywhere since he invented it
sociology and religion uh another
individual by the name of Hans Kung not
but
Kung uh a Catholic Theologian wrote a
number of books using paradigms or
Coon's thesis in order to understand
religious uh Concepts you don't have to
agree with him but I think it's very
fascinating you should read those if you
want how do we show atheists that they
can't justify reason to begin with when
they criticize Islam
first you have to first you have to
undermine their understanding of
science if you can show that they can't
justify the reason through
science then what's the point in doing
anything else I mean there there I mean
they are technically using their reason
to justify their scientific
understanding it's just that their
scientific understanding just doesn't
justify the reason it doesn't work that
way so they're just shooting themselves
in the
foot
what do you think about plantinga's
argument against naturalism I think it's
very clever it's a very clever argument
um I think it has a lot of Merit but I
think he needs to work on it a little
bit more I'm not very convinced about
his idea about warranted I don't I don't
like his his idea about basic beliefs
that's the thing that I really have
contention with I think he's being very
circular I think a better uh Source
would be Michael humor uh
h m
r he came up with an interesting uh
concept called phenomenal conservatism
phenomenal okay phenomenal
conservativism okay where he basically
states that um we are Justified to
believe something if we if if we
perceive it to be that way until more
data comes in that defeats that
perception which to me seems very common
sensical um because that's how we
normally act
anyway what do Western philosophers say
about testimony or mass transmitt
information as a source of knowledge
it's obviously required um imma in
Western
philosophy uh can be challenged but
generally is accepted especially with
regard to Scientific understanding in
experiments in normal science as it were
that said uh imma can be challenged if
the
interpretation is not validating the
observations so for example if every
scientist if 99% of the scientists in
the world subscribe to
Theory only because they don't have a
better alternative and their theory is
is starting to accumulate all these
problems and then a 1% come along and
say hey we got this new
idea uh then in that sense they can
challenge them you see what I'm saying
so it's more holistic it's not there's
not one criteria or the other that can
challenge the imma it has to be there's
a whole see the problem is that I have
with a lot of philosophy modern
philosophy not necessarily contemporary
but modern philosophy is that there's a
demarcation between the objective realm
and the subjective whereas you know in
the Islamic tradition especially and
even in contemporary philosophy that's
not the case uh the objective and
subjective are not different in fact
they're very much the same because like
I said you can't you can't really
demarcate them I mean the only
perspective you have is your own right
and you only confirm it with others you
can't just like jump into other people's
brains
isn't basic belief similar to fitra no
it's
not um I'm not GNA get into that too but
it's not it he uses fit three sort of
arguments but it it's not similar not my
opinion I could be wrong but it's not
not according to me I studied under one
of when I was doing my bachelor's degree
I studied under one of the students of
pla
um he was my my
supervisor and um you know he confirmed
to me a lot of his
ideas I I became interested in planning
it during that time but I didn't agree
with him
necessarily what is the difference
between platina performed epistemology
and fit argument fitter argument deals
primarily with natural inclination
whereas planninga tries to establish
beliefs in such a way that they're
they're sort of like what's the
word uh it's not it's not necessarily
based on intuition let me just put it
that way like fual arguments are based
on intuitionist beliefs or or the
concept of intuitionism whereas pla is
like non-reducible uh self-evident
ideas right like foundational views
foundational
beliefs um whereas the fitra is not a
foundational belief the fit is an
inclination it's a it's a it's a it's a
state of being it's a state of
perceiving it's not it's not a belief in
and of itself do you understand that's
that's the difference so plan is like
this is basic beliefs not
beliefs perception
inclination not according to me f is not
for me f is an inclination towards
belief in God it's not a belief in of
itself when you were born as a baby you
do not believe you don't you don't have
a concept with God in your head
if you're a baby do you understand what
can you can you comprehend Mercy can you
me you can you can perceive it you
can you see what I'm saying like you can
experience it but you don't you can't
tell me what it is as a baby you don't
understand you don't even understand
what a word is
right
um is there an Islamic epistemology
there are many gazali was one as
epistemologist
who came up with this sort of first type
of empiricism within the Islamic
tradition I Tamia was in was also very
much empiricist in in many ways not
completely but in many ways uh Ian haam
was probably the greatest empiricist in
our
tradition very good philosopher as
well how do we get good at recognizing
fallacies practice practice not making
them um
try spotting them as well like if you
study a fallacy say like what is an ad
harim and then look for them it's
practice it's same thing as language how
do you get good at that you got to
practice there's so many
fallacies but you can catch them over
time it takes practice you got to debate
more as well not like in a bad way I
don't want you going around yelling at
people but you know what I mean like
have more discussions with people so you
can see how people practice their
arguments and then practice your own
make sure you're not trying to commit
any
the best best the first thing you should
do is you always have integrity most
people who commit fallaces are people
who don't have any Integrity they're
people who who just want to win a
discussion that's the
problem
um so that's why they commit so many
fallacies do you have an attend Isam do
you have reading material English on
Islamic epistemology kazali Andia yes uh
the best person to look at right now for
contemporary gazelian epistemology would
be
Muhammad who's Malaysian he wrote the
pr the pr of Islamic metaphysics or PR
of Islamic science I forgot the exact
title but it notes PR just look up alas
alas Malaysian philosopher you will find
his
work um he's very contemporaneous in
that sense um
say uh in terms of the pragst tradition
it would be Z zodin sarder zodin
sarder zodin sarder excuse me he is a
pragmatist Islamic philosopher I don't
agree with him by the way on all his his
his Islamic beliefs but uh his his his
philosophy in terms of science is very
good so once again thank you
again